look you could just you could just look
from our seats right here watching this
game and that was a different feel on
that Boston side the intensity level was
up the uh
there were Smiles on that side there was
a Vibe on that side we haven't seen in
this series yet yeah I agree 100 but
also I'm not one to microwave every game
and say oh they're back or I know I
agree with you I think that that was a
better sign tonight because I think the
one thing that you know when at the
beginning it didn't show you asked me I
said I just have a belief in brown and
Tatum that they're gonna get they're not
gonna just fold over and get swept
because they are the winningest duel in
the last five to six years in basketball
so they're gonna get that to me
I think this was an easier game than
game five because if that because of
game five now because and this is my
reasoning
when you go back home now you're not
going home to chat station you're going
trap being chastised you're getting pat
on the back and so now you can feel like
oh well we didn't get swept all right
and then all of a sudden you can relax
and and not feel the urgency that your
season is over if you lose again so they
have to get rid of that feeling
stay out of the places to get pat on the
back to realize your season's over
though if you lose next game and I and I
disagree with that I think game five is
going to be a cakewalk for the Celtics I
think they're going to have so much
energy because when not getting swept is
not a it's not it's not they don't
get a cookie
but now they're going to go back home
that place gonna be loud and incredible
I think they're gonna kill Miami next
game and they're going to come back down
here and I'm gonna tell you something
else game six in Miami gonna be game
seven for Miami uh I said the same time
then you just say uh I said the same
thing about Charlie we coming to see you
I was gonna oh I'm Henry little Henry
becoming I thought I was the Celtics Hey
listen give them credit Jason Tatum
stepped up you know shaqman said yo man
when you're the star you got to step up
Jason Tatum first of all he wins four
games in before he scored a basket in
the fourth quarter that can't happen to
a superstar in any playoff series but
I'm telling you they got no chance that
it's a cakewalk I said I said they it's
okay remember I said that I'm gonna
remember I said it when I call my bookie
I'm gonna say whatever I can bet give it
to me but you said it was a cakewalk
before the season start before the
series started
yeah but I didn't think deception was
going to play like dogs for three games
[Music]
but I'm telling you though when you pick
a series you assume A team's gonna play
good I didn't realize it was going to
take the Celtics four games to play now
that was the such a team we've seen
pretty much all year I have zero idea
what happened in the game one two and
three especially game three that Celtics
play well however Miami is saying 16
turnovers not us eight from 32 from
three not us Miami's Gonna Be Ready
gonna be focused Celtics gonna have to
continue to play away and Tatum and
Browns will have to step up I know
they're home and all that but
little A.D is she's a little up and down
if he plays like he played plays play
tonight you got to ride this emotion off
this game tonight if you're the Celtics
I mean they played brown Brown's got to
pick it up yesterday I mean Tatum played
great tonight but Brown is to me the guy
got to pick it up it can't be the night
was a one punch it's got to be a one-two
punt Miami's not gonna go away for 32.
I agree with checking this point because
the same way it's a human nature of like
going in the same thing that Miami had
they're out here practicing for the
Trophy presentation before the game
they're at the other they have a whole
ceremony they bring people in to give
out the Eastern Conference championship
trophy you're aware of all of this going
on yes you are and you can relax
both antennas will be up in game five if
these teams both Play Good the Celtics
have more Talent let's